hier habe ich beschäftigt eigentlich
dass wir uns seit zwei jahren mit der
korona faust begrüßen einige hatten ja
sogar den crooner ellbogen dann in den
haben sich seine größte beziehung gerade
also die begrüßungsrituale sozusagen
bekannten eigentlich gar kein limit hier
sehen wir das auch noch mal und ich muss
sagen diese krone faust ii geht mir
zunehmend auf die nerven ich fordere den
handschlag den anschlag der steht für
ehrlichkeit der steht für
zuverlässigkeit wissen dass der anschlag
vor gericht sogar auch als justiziabel
gilt wer einen deal ab schließt per
handschlag und die fakten geklärt und
auf beiden seiten der kann sich dann
auch am ende darauf verlassen so was
zumindest früher und das war früher
alles gar nicht so schlecht deswegen
fordere ich auch als hoffnungsschimmer
der hand lag wusste zurück und ich würde
ganz gerne eigentlich in dieser runde
anfange mit dem
ich bin auch sehr dafür dass der
anschlag zurückkehrt ist würde ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich verwundern aber ich fand
ja ganz lächerlich den ellbogen weil
damit kann man sicher näher als mancher
der hand gekommen wäre und auch mit der
faust berührt man übrigens ja auch
irgendwo sich ich finde auch der hand
schlagen muss zurückkehren es wäre auch
wieder ein zeichen der normalität und
die handhygiene hat ja auch eigentlich
jeder selber drauf wissen ja wie sieht
dieses video betrieb des rk ii sagt
selbst haupt übertragung durch die luft
ja ja und wenn dann gibt es auch auf
metallenen
flächen rückstände aber eigentlich so
gut wie gar nicht hier an der hand und
ob ich nun so mache oder ob ich so mache
und mir danach beispielsweise die hände
wasche
wasser einweichen und herren findet wenn
man der politik gelegen die
symbolpolitik formel würde ich sagen ist
das auch eine symbol forderung aber ich
meine am ende hast du natürlich recht
wir haben jahrzehnte lang aerosol
forschung inzwischen betrieben so kommt
anders vor und wir wissen dass es dann
doch vielleicht nicht die
tröpfcheninfektion ist diese überträgt
also von mir auch sehr gerne vielleicht
wäre es ein schönes symbol um da wieder
rauszukommen entscheiden wird es nicht
sein aber es gibt hoffnung ich das mal
sagen darf also diese wenn man sagt der
wunsch zurück zu kommen zu einem leben
in freiheit und
schließen das was wir vorher auch erlebt
haben dann ist doch herr lehmann wenn
ich ihnen jetzt die hand hier so gebe
einen tisch ist das doch wertschätzung
auch in den hafen von mahdia toren
bringen werden ja nicht nur el sol
forschung gemacht jahrzehntelang sondern
auch handschlag forscht jahrhundert
sehen bei den jahrhundertelangen bei
allen epidemien bei cholera bei
gelbsucht bei der spanischen grippe
überall ist danach der anschlag zurück
gekommen selbst unsere engsten
verwandten oder nächsten verwandten der
schimpanse sie schimpfen sie begrüßen
sich veranschlagt also den handschlag
machen ich mir keine sorgen nicht
zwischen dem von armut und markus söder
aber generell wird er zurückgezogen
trotzdem ist das jetzt nicht kein thema
ich wäre er dafür dass wir darüber reden
dass wir im einzelhandel wieder zweig
haben das ist abgeschafft wird dass das
nicht noch ist also in bayern ist es
abgeschafft im saarland die gerichte
haben es abgeschafft nicht die politik
sie unterschätzen die symbol würde ich
erst einmal sagen darf also wenn sie
können frei sie können sagen für mich
kein thema ich halte das für ein
entscheidendes thema es gibt diese
tollen fotos der bundeskanzlerin mit
maske zweimal geimpft damals noch zu
einer gm stand begrüßt sich trotzdem mit
hat mit mit diesem ellbogencheck mit
frau von der leyen beispielsweise das
ist doch an absurdität entschuldigung
also das so sage nicht so über
vielleicht sollten wir ja uns mal andere
kulturen angucken denn ich weiß noch wie
ich es früher immer belächelt haben und
komisch warnt wenn ich irgendwelche
berichte aus china fand oder auch wenn
ich in asiatische länder gereist bin
dass viele menschen auf der straße immer
masken trugen und ich wusste man gar
nicht beim tragen die dann immer masken
und so haben diese ohne angst sich
irgendwie anzustecken mit einmal tragen
wir alle masken aber auch gerade die
asiaten die inder und die thailänder die
begrüßen sich so eben weil sie nicht
gerne wären übertragen das sind eben
auch alles länder wo es mit der hygiene
nicht so gut bestellt ist und ich finde
dass sie doch sehr eleganter aus wir
müssen wir uns mal an tatschen also
vielleicht wäre das ja auch eine
noch so
der wichtige punkt ist natürlich ist es
etwas etwas humorvoll natürlich auch
wenn man darüber spricht aber ich glaube
auch dass es ein ganz ganz wichtiger
punkt zurückzukehren und wieder ins
normale leben zu kehren ich finde schon
sehr anstrengend dass man nie weiß wie
man sich bin ja also immer wieder
einsetzte ist mal ein zipfel dass aber
auch beim lange handschlag hat der
wertschätzung beim handschlag schaut man
sich ja auch in die augen bei der korona
faust guckt jeder hauptsache ich treffe
ich das dirigat
ist mir böse gestimmt also ich find der
handschlag der tritt vielmehr aus herr
lehmann ja ich bin ich bin kein
berühmter ist nicht denn jetzt im
bundestag weil man sich denn da so
trifft im saal werden sich denn aktuelle
grün ist frei
nein aber ich weiß nicht wie es wäre
logisch ist aber jetzt die viren
übertragung weil man ja schon mit der
handfläche die schleimhäute er berührt
ohne dass man es merkt augen nase mund
und da macht man es nicht bin kein
biologe aber das könnte wahrscheinlich
oder ist wahrscheinlich der grund gibt
es dann irgendwo auf diesem globus schon
einen standort wo man sich wieder die
hände geht der schäfer also hier
beispielsweise wir haben es kann aber
auch jeder möchten wir wollen ja auch
keinen zu nahe treten das ist wieder der
punkt in der kommune ein panini man weiß
nie wie aber gibt's schon ort also ich
würde sagen dass beispielsweise in
amerika schon auch empfänger der orden
wieder mehr freiheit einzug gehalten hat
und ich habe letztens mit dem schweizer
telefoniert er war sehr verwundert wie
viel unserer zeitung noch voll sind mit
dem corona themen also vielleicht war es
nur von ihnen ansichtssache aber ich
glaube wir haben schon mehr orte wo
wieder freiheit herrscht
absolut also ich bin auch ein großer fan
von hendrik strikt der optimistisch ist
und dieses auch ausstrahlt
weil ich meine dass wir jetzt nicht auf
das thema impfpflicht kommen so man
sieht ja auch in der bevölkerung geht
das jetzt anders gesehen das thema m
fliegt wenn ich die aktuellen umfrage
fragen sehe wie vor ein paar monaten ich
war immer schon kritisch und wenn alle
jetzt sagen ja und micon werden sie auch
dafür gegen die impfpflicht aus dem
absolut und und vielleicht machen wir da
nur ein vorratsbeschluss und das spüren
die menschen die wollen doch raus ja und
wenn man jetzt wieder ein neue maßnahmen
diskutiert und hinterher wieder eine
große enttäuschung ist weil die panini
immer noch da ist ja dann ist auch
nichts gewollten dann kommt wieder die
politikverdrossenheit und es wird immer
mehr und deswegen müssen wir jetzt
wirklich raus nach vorne bringen wird es
noch dauern
meine frau
weiß ich nicht ich höre halt zu wenn er
strebt beispielsweise sagt dass jetzt
die die virus lassen zu sagen ihr seid
die rohs dampf zurückgeht etwas mehr ja
auch die auswirkung dass die dass die
folgen bilder sind ja auch die
nebenwirkungen etc dass das dann zu
einer emmy werden kann macht mir das
hoffnung da muss sich die frage stellen
wie lange dauert es noch unter einem
kanzler scholz und wie lange würde es
beim kanzler märz dauern
bei herrn scholz ist ja mal ganz
interessant
man muss ja ich dreimal erstmal zuhören
was er überhaupt sich meint also ich hab
den letzten live gesehen im deutschen
bundestag du stellst in frage also die
hat eine unglaubliche
eigenschaft dinge dann immer auf
flughöhe zu beantworten also selbst wenn
man eben diese frage stellen würde hätte
man vermutlich danach keine antwort
friedrich merz der ist jetzt richtig zug
drin wir haben am wochenende unserem
parteitag gehabt haben eine erste
bundesvorstandssitzung hat die dauerte
30 minuten da war richtig zug drin wir
haben jetzt alle bock in der welt
ja das tut uns doch auch mal gut oder
würde es ihnen nicht auch tut das nicht
mal diese stunde gut dass wir unser
handy einfach mal gezählt liegen haben
ich fand sie trotzdem wollen wichtig
dass danach der vorstand auch wieder ein
paar informationen raus gekommen und man
kann ich auch menschen danach anrufen
also ganz so versuchen braucht das nicht
die erste bundesvorstandssitzung aber
ich glaube das ist auch unfair wir
wissen es schlicht lich wir wissen es
schlicht nicht wie lange sie dauert man
kann das weder von olaf scholz noch von
friedrich merz erfragen was ich erwartet
ist im dritten jahr der pandemie dass
wenn wir jetzt wieder niedrige zahlen
kommen und das wird ja im märz april
nach lage der virologen so kommen dass
wir dann vorbereitungen haben dass wir
einfach dieses mal ausnahmsweise
vorbereitungen für den herbst für den
winter falls eben doch eine neue
variante kommt das erwarte ich von der
politik damit meine ich nicht die
allgemeine impfpflicht aber ich meine
sie an anderer stelle wir haben zwei mal
gnadenlos versagt und spätsommer
prävention scheint mehr teil der politik
zu sein und das müssen wir dieses jahr
anders machen und wie lange sie dann
dauert es dass wir wegen es mal
luftreinigung filter bekommen für die
studie haben wir bis heute ja nicht die
schulen besser ausstatten und so damit
die kinder in die schule gehen können
ohne angst haben zu müssen dass wenn sie
nach hause kommen ihrer ganzen familie
anstecken und alle sind dann in
quarantäne und dann fahren keine busse
weil die busfahrer krank sind und und
und
meine daten keine echtzeitdaten wir
können gar nicht sagen wie ist die
intensiv belegungssituation gerade
wirklich wir wissen es sich krömer
der charité chef hat bei der bund länder
sitzung jetzt gerade gefleht bitte
organisiert mir ein digitalisiertes
gesundheitswesen damit für echtzeitdaten
haben und entscheidungen treffen können
und da war dann schweigen in der runde
das ist einfach nur noch peinlich